we're gonna we're gonna knife the [ __ ]
out of this box and show you what's
inside man and we're trying to do it in
two versions me and J are trying to do
what's on the box what's in the box on
J's twitch tilt your screen now so it's
not so much Headroom
there you go sexy I can see our feet
know we're real and here we're doing
what's up in the box on my facebook life
so we're trying to double fist maybe
well what's in the box so we just did
the greeting here let's do the greeting
here man what's up there
welcome to another scintillating episode
of what's in the box
I'm Jay I'm selling Bob that's right man
and this week we are gonna dive into let
me show you the box kids dude there she
is there she is
look at that box look at that box you're
in the way oh Jesus Christ
there's the box ladies and gentlemen
there's Jay's YouTube thing and stuff
and so Jay has a [ __ ] knife let me
turn this away it's so funny because I
have this knife set as well but yours
has a curve to it so I don't know if
that gives it a little more just like my
dick yeah this is not a product shot but
it's a global knife but look at this
month Michael Meyers looking [ __ ] no
doubt and classic Halloween all right
man we give J as we do in every episode
the knife I'm gonna turn it around so we
could focus on him doing it alright let
me get in front I don't wanna be cut by
your knife and [ __ ] not also don't want
to get in the way of your show
alright here we go man right we put my
nighter alright don't take anything out
yet no all right so so far the box
hasn't opened it's been knifed what is
in the box
this is a box that came from our friends
at Spin Master last week they gave us a
bunch of
Batman figures Batman toys to open up
which was awesome so they sent us
another box we me and Jason Mewes are
about to find out what's in that box all
right kid take that out oh I see pop
that is Marvel's agents of shield that
would be I don't know if that is
Marvel's I think this Hydra first well
hold on listen
yeah you really are and also this is
like the worst angle in the world and
what I go get my dick cam my man
regardless all right so hold on I'm
gonna turn this around where's this hat
passage right about now here I will come
on this side right about now we're
mission missing the [ __ ] out of Josh
I'll tell you that man budget kid's
budget and [ __ ] so here we are trying to
make it work for ourselves okay he's got
his [ __ ] thing behind him which is
now my ass shot this is terrible you
know you're covering cuz the box which
is great
fair enough all right man so now Jay for
the last time ever by ourselves without
Josh Roush yes what is in the box
I already feel like I pulled out the one
so I feel like I gotta continue even
though I see other things I'm curious
about but this is this guy are you drunk
all right boy Jay hold on hold on let me
Beauty shot it Oh
all right here here over here yeah you
show your people that is pretty sweet
man what is it exactly
all right so it is knowledge of English
required that's what you go for you go
right for like the [ __ ] warnings what
is it say up top don't knife it yet holy
[ __ ] let's study the box hail to the new
world order hail Hydra
deception deduction destruction perhaps
it tells us somewhere on the side it is
it may be the back I feel like the back
would be the best there it is the battle
is on but who can you trust
hail Hydra is a game where each player
has a soit's
yes some players are shield and some are
Hydra but you won't know which is which
there's lying finger-pointing and
persuasion as you deduce I've always
wanted to use that word deduce who is
working with the team and who is not
alright so it's a hell hide your game
ensure open it up let's look inside
oh that's the kingpin yes sir Wow and
there's a really great rendering
character yeah ten all right here we go
you did have to use the knife after all
yeah for this little side piece
featuring 14 heroes 18 villains from
Marvel Universe metal Avengers tower
included what Avengers a tower is
avengers tower is included and it's
metal alright open that [ __ ] up open it
open it
oh hold on all those characters the game
I'll read them off CPU involve um green
goblin up the over here there's Baron
Zemo right how's the Red Skull yes right
here Ultron right here Wilson Fisk the
kingpin is that crossbones
no no that's that taskmaster taskmaster
yes there's MODOK up there is there a
Hydra no no I think that's what's your
sister no I don't know - Varla wish
Scarlet Witch oh that's nice over here
we got we got the Hulk of course we got
Black Widow we've got a Spider Man like
Panda yes you call him out by pant David
Captain America electrons electron
electric daredevil Iron Man and spider
Gwen that's right so folks watching at
home who are these two you're right it
yes sorry guys I would show you but oh
we don't we're in LA yeah over there on
J speed I guess you can't hear show it
to J speech
they're feeding it in we got the
information come on back
it is taskmaster no but that's that's
crossbones I think I was right and I
think that is meant to be taskmasters
what they're saying to us folks confirm
you're saying that's that doesn't look
like Testament no I think he's got the
skull face and this and the sword bones
don't right so that is any as a cape
bones doesn't have a cape so I'm sorry
guys that is taskmaster at the bottom
and the guy on top I believe he is it
look he is Captain America star on his
chest so I believe he is a patriot of
some sort interesting all right let's
pull something let's see the pieces blue
and they might even have the answers
here oh my god they will well no see
there's crossbones yeah yeah so who are
those cats open these bad guy cards and
let's find out who yes let me see the
few hours you get a little Avengers
Tower
Tony's Tower from New York and stuff got
yourself you know you could be shield or
something else we all know it is alright
let's find out her number
here we go we got crossbones pop we have
here it is sight know that psychic Bob
agent Bob agent of Hydra that's awesome
Bob agent of Hydra okay electrocute
whiplash abomination Baron von Strucker
okay constrictor
Arnim Zola Madame masque Baron Zemo
kingpin Ultron Green Goblin
MODOK taskmaster right so we were right
with the sack for a dad toy bro
that one I was that's new to me I did
not know that Madame ha I said lady
Hydra I think fair enough he's the
winner will stop the heroes let's see
what heroes we get to play with as we
dive over here I love that we also
figure out careful your bandwidth that
night you used to be a reckless youth
and in a reckless fashion now all right
here we go here we go Captain America
Black Widow Nick Fury Sharon Carter who
Sharon Carter makes appearance fighter
man spider-gwen the Hulk
she-hulk Iron Man quake daredevil
Elektra Black Panther wasp Captain
America we're back at the beginning Wow
guys they had some new guys I mean I
feel like looking at that team-up that's
a beautiful box yeah it's all in the
hands of the players son all right let's
see something else pull something
outside of this box while here while
you're telling I'll tell him what's
going on so Jay is live streaming on his
twitch channel right now as we speak as
you see him wearing a giant saw about
shirt
Jay is streaming on his twitch channel
and when we're done doing what's in the
box he's gonna continue streaming on
twitch channel he'll be doing what
gaming maybe do a giveaway or two oh
that's right so what you want to do is
if you like this stuff well thought of
if you like the stuff that we're opening
they gave it to us and we get to give it
away so you go over to Jay's twitch
channel what's it called Jay Mewes JY w
es twitch that's the one that he's on
right now behind us in the background on
the laptop you go over there and we'll
be able to you can win these man you'll
win whatever are you gonna give it away
you
you can everyone puts a word in
you pick a word like Hydra everyone puts
in Hydra and whoever gets in it gets a
ticket a ticket ticket at the end I hit
pick a winner and it automatically
generates a winner which is great no no
no it was smith who said that first and
I think I see here that it was sewing
sewing a big no-no so you know all right
next one this is worth riveted by that
[ __ ] tail it's called Connor utter
Reed minutes Marvel 5-minute Marvel 15
minute more 5 minute Marvel 5-minute
Marvel and in here let's do the bag of
the Box battles done class yeah sorry I
me get this off I didn't want to get
ahead of myself right here we go claim
your hero battle the villains defeat the
boss you and your team of Marvel heroes
are locked in an epic battle with bosses
villains minions Squirrel Girl
goons conquer each mission in 5 minutes
or less to win done to the don't open
that box what's in the box what's in the
box
I love how people draw the same
characters differently in different
oh yeah look at that Loki boss by lost
one boss to MODOK boss Mike ant-man
Ultron Ultron we saw in the movie 6 is a
nose I wonder who he is
alright so it's a bar it's a card game
dummy Black Widow
uh and then it has Captain America
rocket and Groot spider-gwen Hulk Iron
Man Medusa what is Medusa foam can you
answer the Inhumans
and dinner oh my god man we are having a
blast opening up a box Watson
you
in the box with Jay and Silent Bob here
the good folks at Spin Master who sent
us Batman toys Larry it's one of those
card games you pick a card it tells you
what you do you win you get knocked out
you beat someone up it's all that stuff
you know so but they have different ones
web-shooters defeat any card with the
pink on it so their card games pick them
choose win battle these are these are
great Jeanette Robinson said this would
be a fun to play with kids that one
absolutely looked like it would be fun
to play with kids all right man
we got one no two games left man pull
that one out Jake what's in that box
[Applause]
Santorini man Santorini just leave me
alone
what is it it says builds like a mortal
win like a god ooh like that so what is
it the back wait look it over why is
this a Gordon Hamilton is like the
people who make games get to put their
names on it like yes yes yes I get
credit [ __ ]
yeah it had somebody's name on it what
did it say yeah so wow they're letting
like the game authors they're rock stars
but it looks like you get to build the
vacuum I'm wondering if you have
yourself a little palace look a cliff
pedestal and you get up look at me look
at me
you know how we find out what's in the
box
[Music]
yeah you get to build some [ __ ] your lie
your twitch is going and people are like
we can't see [ __ ] you got a so [ __ ] but
you know i'ma try to show you look at
him to shows the clips okay let's bring
it in for a look at the product I
you see
hmm see that in awesome oh my god how
awesome is that
I am sorry guys I'm gonna show him again
whoa Dugan that's awesome man
welcome to and I'm Jay and I'm selling
Bob we're gonna we're gonna knife the
[ __ ] out of this box and show you what's
inside man and we're trying to do it in
two versions me and Jay are trying to do
what's on the box what's in the box on
Jays twitch tilt your screen does
you
he would alright we have one left here
we go man this is pretty cool so again
what is that a movie game for anyone who
has ever seen a movie from big potato
games holy crap
part two is triple jeopardy and let the
good times roll this actually looks dope
and it looks like a big ol blockbuster
open it open up open they're open that
is [ __ ] dope a plus for packaging be
kind please your wine lover that makes
me sound metals [ __ ] oh boy
let's see I'm sorry I don't want to miss
as if it looks like it does it become
something oh this is the board that's
clever
quote it act it one word acting okay so
looks like we go across from one another
right so then you go through it so let's
make sure what is the read aim aim be
the first team clearly an animation and
sci-fi and fantasy play each team
chooses a player to represent them in
the head-to-head round I was right a
head-to-head round they're dead brown
both players from each team sit opposite
each other with the buzzer in front of
them count down from three then flip
over at dead card this will reveal of
random categories such as movies with
dogs so movies with dogs so then I go
pink and I'd say Lassie a new hip
dang it does but I might show you when
you put batteries in it goes like me me
me yeah hold on there's an on/off button
I heard something didn't work I don't
think there's a battery battery not
included kids but so then you buzz in
and it would probably make a noise or
something yes and the cool thing is is
then you pick a thing if you give a
classy and then you're the winner and
check this out as a little sign here I'm
going to put the sticker on it
blockbuster science you can feel like
you're in there oh look at this look at
the first one brings back memories Hans
Groos oh yeah yeah things like ray of
memories that is dope man read open up
and is there a question cuz I thought it
was said like movies with dogs and I got
that because war is it like you give the
word and they lost in trance so it looks
like movies with ghosts ghosts Patrick
Swayze but he's a winner it's just that
simple
and it says you acted out though so I
guess it depends on what one word quoted
active that this is where you park your
movie cards when ready so oh wait acted
as an option oh yes I wonder if I'd is
getting excited oh so so it says die
hard and you like quoted and I'm like
yippie-ki-yay [ __ ] yes
um and then what's the other one
thrilling act it would be
boss this is often the cops inside the
cop car talking to you tire or you could
be Alice the guy with the cocaine
problem and [ __ ] so you can be like yeah
you're like john-boy I'm your knight in
shining armor yeah that's a fun game I
want to play it's a good idea man all
right so that is a [ __ ] fun we're
keeping this one game yeah yeah but the
rest are up for grabs man if you go to
Jay's twitch channel right now what is
it Jamie's Jay why I mean yes download
the app or if you don't have it just go
to twitch calm Jay Mewes
he's gonna be playing games up here on
the my deck and he's gonna give away
those games and stuff so you can win
some games thank you to the good folks
at Spin Master for giving us something
to do today we had something to do we
got to go on the internet and have a
little bit of fun give some stuff away
man everyone stays safe wash your hands
thank you to all the frontline workers
out there and went on people that
deliver our meals and the doctors the
nurses especially everyone be good Jay
for Jay and Silent Bob how did we end
this yeah it's like for Jane for what's
in the box that's it for what's in the
bottle we do do that to begin at the end
for what's in the box I'm care I've been
Kevin Smith Jason Mewes and what's in
the box there's been a bunch of cool
[ __ ]
you